Before we say goodbye, we like to play a quick round of...
Drewth or dare.
(crowd cheers and claps)
And we have today, Christina Yanas.
Hi Christina.
Hi guys.
Hi. Cute, fitting in our color story today.
I know, what a surprise.
Thank you.
Thank you. You.
All right, what's it gonna be?
A Drewth or a dare?
I'm gonna pick Drewth.
Okay.
Okay, So my Drewth is,
is have either of you ever done an Irish exit
such as leaving a party or an event
without saying goodbye to anyone?
And if so, when?
Is that rude?
(crowd laughs)
Yes, I think it is a little.
Well, okay.
Actually, I think it depends on the size
and I will tell you why.
If you're at an intimate dinner party
I think an exit without saying thank you and goodbye,
is totally weird.
If you're at a large party, what are you gonna do?
Tell everybody? Make a whole 30 minutes of it?
I totally agree with you.
No, just leave.
100%. If it's intimate, you know,
you go around, you give the hug, you do the thing,
but if you're at a big thing
and I can't find you, I gots to go.
"90 Day Fiance" is on at home.
I have things to do.
Yes, 100%
Tell them I said bye.
(crowd claps)
What do you think, Christina?
When was the last time you did that?
Or do you frown upon such behavior?
Oh, I actually do it all the time, it's horrible.
(crowd laughs)
Wait, all the time?
A decent amount.
I feel like it's bad, but I do it.
My mom and I do it a lot when we go to family parties.
We have a big family and it takes like,
if we're gonna say goodbye, it's gonna take an hour.
So we're just gonna leave.
Yeah. Yeah, and here's the move, right.
Hey, I looked for you to say goodbye
but I couldn't find you.
(crowd laughs)
Ooh.
That is good and diabolical, right, but it works.
You also can definitely send a text to say,
(crowd claps)
"I had the best time, thank you so much",
like that night, 'cause you know
they're not really checking it until the next day.
And then you look like that guy who, like,
did some toe dip in, in some format.
Yeah.
All right, well good.
Good. I hope that helped.
Yes. Thank you.
You're welcome. Thank you.
(crowd cheers and claps)
Speaking of goodbyes,
we wanna thank you for choosing to spend your time with us.
And we make this show for you, so...
Take it with you.
(upbeat music)